ich habe mir heute die haare mal nicht
gemacht und ich haben pflaster am finger
hier
deshalb wundert euch nicht als ich habe
mich geschnitten so häufig nur vorne weg
sein würde was kita-platz willkommen
beim ein video und zwar habe ich circa
vor einer woche ich glaube genau vor
einer woche schon wieder rausgehen das
hieß das mädchen nicht tragen sollen der
titel vielleicht ein bisschen gewagt
gewählt wie dieser jetzt auch hier aber
egal auf jeden fall vorher mit dem video
heute anfangen wollte erstmals ein
kleines statement zu dem video was
letzte woche rausgehauen habe also was
mädchen nicht tragen sollten sagen weil
ich kann verstehen dass manche das
vielleicht nicht ganz so akzeptieren
oder sagen ja es kann doch jeder tragen
was der welt ich habe doch genau das
gleiche erstmal vorweg auch gesagt nur
was manche der reihe interpretieren ich
versteh's nicht wie kann man denn so
viel da also das was ich beziehungsweise
wie er da gesagt haben das war nur
unsere meinung muss niemand vertreten
und es waren jetzt wird fand ich so
wirklich auch nicht so wie sachen die
wirklich so viele leute tragen natürlich
es gibt leute die sowas tragen aber im
endeffekt sollte das ganze video
eigentlich nur so ein bisschen
unterhaltung sein werden jedes meiner
videos ich meine ich krieg auf pro tag
zehn mal gehört wie ich meine haare denn
zu tragen habe dass sie mal zu langen
sind mal zu kurz denn im endeffekt ist
es mir so was von scheißegal ich meine
ich trag wie so wie ich möchte mir sah
kaufleute hey deine hose scheiße sieg
eine jogginghose an in die schule oder
sowas ab und zu trotzdem ich meine was
andere leute dazu sagen es ist einfach
eine unterhaltung zieht euch an wie ihr
wollt und ich habe jetzt auch überhaupt
nichts gegen euch wenn ihr halt mal so
rumlaufen rumlaufen und ich es halt
nicht so toll finde was ist daran so
weiß ich nicht ich habe gar nicht
gecheckt die man da so viel rein
interpretieren kann ich meine ich kann
zwar verstehen dass er sagt ja du hast
zuschauer die sind 13 oder 14 und die
senica als vorbild die tragen dass jetzt
nicht weil du es gesagt hast aber ganz
ehrlich so meine ich das auch hier kein
anziehen was ihr wollt ich habe euch
trotzdem alle lieb und nämlich immer
alles so hart ist einfach nur ein
bisschen unterhaltungen ganz bisher auch
meine meinung fertig so das reicht jetzt
auch erstmal aber bei mir so viele leute
war sagen hey du könnt ihr sie
ist immer noch was an mädchen weil ich
eine junge band macht doch bitte auch
mal was du an jungs blöd findet das
gibt's heute satz jungs niemals tragen
sollte interpretiert bitte nicht so viel
ein wie letztes mal ganz schnell ich
einfach nur meine meinung und los geht's
wir fangen erst mal ganz locker an sowie
glaube ich 99 97 prozent aller jungs
denken und zwar es gibt ja irgendwie als
jungs die mit leggins herumlaufen wie
ich kann euch am main foto ein wenn gut
ist okay dazu würde ich sagen ist jetzt
nicht ganz so ein fall
außer der prinz der darf das kleiner gag
am rande und ja was aber auch viele
jungs tragen so in meinem alter im
verlauf meiner schule das sind diese
skinny jeans heißen die glaube ich habe
davon auf welche aber die sind wirklich
nicht ganz menge also ich trag nicht so
gerne so weiter sondern schon ein
bisschen eng aber es gibt davon wirklich
so varianten die sind so fucking das
sieht doch einfach nur scheiße aus oder
ich meine ihr seht darin aus wie sau mit
gequetschten bratwurst im bratwurst
teller
wie heißt diese bringe keine ahnung auf
jeden fall denke ich mir dabei manchmal
so warum warum bitte warum und kann ja
auch sein dass neue ich das so sehe
können gerne eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare schreiben
da können wir aber mit schönen
diskutieren so dann würde ich sagen wir
machen weiter und zwar ist jetzt zur
zeit so voll im trend ihr kennt
zwischenlager dieses black fashion hin
und her ich habe es auch in meinem
letzten video also was mädchen meiner
meinung nach nicht tragen sollten auch
schon angesprochen dass ich bestimmt
voll witzig aus dem pflaster auf jeden
fall dies black fashion ich mein wenn
man es gut trägt so man kann's auch auf
jeden fall vertrage ich hab da überhaupt
nichts gegen es gibt ja leute die sehen
so aus und ich finde es sieht wirklich
cool aus aber es gibt auch leute die
sind 12 und die sehen genauso aus und
das bild was ich hier eben ein gemeldet
habe ich ganz ruhig nochmal einen wenn
die haben es auch meiner meinung nach
schon ein bisschen übertrieben aber
diese zwölf link alter da denke ich ja
du warst vor einem halben jahr sah aus
wie ein normaler mensch und jetzt ist
aus dem t shirt und am t shirt und einem
t-shirt und am t shirt und am t shirt
und manche tragen dann wirklich auf
diese snacks dudi sela mit so scheiße
aufnehmen
was haltet ihr davon wenn 12 oder 13
jährige so rumlaufen wie von einem
anderen planeten black fashion und
danach noch weiter mit punkt 4 ist das
glaube ich jetzt schon und zwar das
betrifft jetzt glaube ich eher sind
ältere generation vielleicht ja auch
manchen von euch ich weiß es nicht auf
jeden fall
ich habe dazu auf ein richtiges schönes
oder richtig schöne zitate von
elitepartner.de gefunden fragt mich
nicht wie ich dahin gelangt bin auf
jeden fall weiter irgendwie plötzlich
mein elitepartner.de profil steht in der
beschreibung wenn ihr heiße abenteuer
sucht dann schreibt mich da doch einfach
mal an ich fand es irgendwie mein ganzes
leben lang schon scheiße aber ich habe
das bis ich 14 war glaube ich noch
getragen und zwar diese sandalen
wisst ihr diese clips dingsbums da wo
man mit aussieht wie begrüßte vollidiot
ich meine wenn du jetzt als mädchen
sondern wirklich geil findet bei männern
dann schreib mir das auf jeden fall in
die kommentare irgendwie bei
elitepartner.de kommen was weiß ich
hatte er gefragt ja wie steht ihr denn
so zu sandalen und dann kann man solche
antworten ich kann euch das ja mal eben
ein blenden so nummer eins schreibt ganz
einfach weil es bescheiden aussieht und
nochmal zwei muss ich ablesen
naja bei mehr alternativen typen mit
gepflegten füßen tagsüber zum
spazierengehen gerade noch akzeptabel
ansonsten muss ich leider sagen ein
absolutes no-go weiblich 29 jahren da
hab das nicht so komme zu punkt 5 und
zwar das ist jetzt irgendwie mit der
zeit sofort ein trend gekommen weil das
auch einige youtube ab und zu mal tragen
hier und ich weiß ich das habt ihr
bestimmt auch schon mal gesehen das sind
diese hüte die eigentlich voll scheiße
aussehen oder das sieht doch mega
verblödet aus ich meinen manchen leuten
stets vielleicht kann sein aber wenn ich
mir zum beispiel diesen diesen gut hier
aussetzen würde passen auch noch ein
bisschen mexikanische musik jetzt ein
ich kann ja mal okay so jetzt schon eher
aber es sieht einfach scheiße aus oder
hier
ich weiß nicht was ihr von jütland von
der gerne auch mal die kommentare
schreiben aber wie gesagt dass wir jetzt
einfach nur noch mal so meine meinung
bisschen hoffe ich unterhaltsam verpackt
ich hoffe ihr schwarze mann jedenfalls
ist der fall es lass mir doch mal gerne
daumen nach oben da würde mich sehr
freuen ansonsten zum anderen teil also
was mädchen nicht machen sollte kommen
die in der video beschreibung ist schon
was einfallen könnte mich gerne denn
hier oben links geht's weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war
von wegen so hier blabla dies das so
dumme dinge die mir so passiert sind
peinliche sachen die mir passiert sind
checkt auf jeden fall april mich bei
aller sonstigen nächsten montag
eventuell nicht wieder weil ich mega
nektar so phasen bin hatte ich halte
euch auch im laufenden überall wo es
geht